who are your favorite skaters now my
favorite skaters now
um Chris Cole has always been like my
all-time favorite him p-rod artosari
Andrew Reynolds those are the guys I
grew up watching uh my favorites like
more current skaters
um ashadware is definitely one of my
favorites
um
Braden Hoban have you heard of him he's
like a newer kid that came up throughout
the past couple years he actually all
just came so close to winning that
Street League contest and he [ __ ] I
wonder if he's uh one of Zeke's
roommates
he is from SD area yeah yeah really they
probably know each other
um but yeah he's so good he has like the
best [ __ ] kickflip we're like in La
Jolla and kickflip into anything it's
crazy how about Tori pudwell I mean he's
kind of like splitting the difference
between like uh you know the new yeah no
Tori's a legend dude she's my favorite
I've always loved him yeah I was
actually very impressed when I watched
his last video part that came out I
think like six months ago and he had
this [ __ ] nollie flip back tail on
this ledge I don't know if you saw it I
did in the longest [ __ ] ledge and
it's also like pretty tall yeah Nolly
flipping into a back tail on a Ledge
like that is already hard and you had it
had to go so fast to slide that whole
thing I was shocked his part at the end
of the the plan B true video like I just
thought was I I would have given you the
gnarliest part and him the most like
technical part yeah I feel like Tori is
a good example of one of those skaters
that is such a legend and that has
always deserved you know just more love
you know
right it's just one of those skaters
that's like put in so many [ __ ] hours
and like been around been Pro been
putting out video parts for so long but
like they're just
I don't know some skaters just don't
really get the love that they really
deserve right just I'm saying because
there's not that much money in
skateboarding you know you would think
someone at his level should be
absolutely [ __ ] killing you know yeah
comparing it to any other sport out
there
I mean what makes somebody like kill it
and not kill in the sport
it's safe to say that there's hundreds
right hundreds of pro skaters
like
of those
of those hundreds of scary I'm not gonna
say a thousand but like hundreds of pro
skaters and the overwhelming majority of
them have to work a regular job that's
[ __ ] crazy bro really for sure crazy
and like of the skaters the really do
well financially very few
and of those skaters
we're sitting with the number one
right like I mean you you're Tony Hawk
right I mean yeah yeah Sheckler well
yeah I mean I mean Tony Hawk's different
though you know it's like I don't really
compare myself to Tony in that sort of
way because he is [ __ ] Tony Hawk like
it's just yeah do you have a video game
coming out soon that we don't know about
maybe one day if anyone else is gonna
have a video game like Tony Hawk did
it'll be Niger and it's crazy too
because like you see like did were you
in a Super Bowl commercial like with
Tony and yeah like Sean White it's just
like icon status man it's rad to be
watching the Super Bowl and see Nigel
with this icon status yeah yes who'd
they team you up with was it Sean White
oh man Tony Hawk I remember yeah but
yeah it was just like on that level it
it's not yeah it really has been
something that's always like just bummed
me out about skateboarding that was like
why considering how [ __ ] big
skateboarding is and like all these
brands that make so much money and like
so much so much like influence and
lifestyle comes out of what we do and
just think about like how many kids
skate all around the world but for some
[ __ ] reason there just isn't like
that much money in it to like well for
people to just live better lives like
you're saying your average pro
skateboarder like even if they don't
have to work a normal job and they just
skate they're still just kind of like
getting by that's like bro you're a
professional what you do shouldn't you
be making a Better Living for yourself
right is it crazy to see how much money
there is actually in in selling your own
board versus uh I mean is that I mean
you don't make a lot of money off the
boards and if you do it yourself you
make a lot more I mean I mean yeah we we
sell a good amount of boards at this
order but like it takes a while to build
up any skate company it doesn't matter
who the [ __ ] is starting it it takes a
while and that's something I've always
learned like watching guys like like
Shane O'Neill start a company and stuff
like he's one of the sickest skaters
ever but it did take him a few years to
really get his company to where it's at
nowadays right I mean the the industry
standard for board royalties for a pro
skater two bucks a board right is that
still the case and
that's factoring in that they've got a
like
run the ads in this keyboard they got
all the marketing money you know and
then they gotta sell the boards to the
shop and then the shops got to mark it
up that's two dollars retail uh like a
wholesale
do big companies like element did they
pay a different board royalty to their
skaters for the direct consumer sales
or this is just two two bucks aboard
across the
across everything it was just the same
see that's not that's why that's why so
many people are just starting their own
company because when you're selling
boards direct to Consumers without the
the skate shop middleman and and you're
doing it on the back of your own social
media so without the marketing dollars
we've signed it for 100 versus 40 to the
you know right Spencers right I mean
it's crazy I I mean I I see it both ways
certainly the profit margin when you're
when you own your own company is going
to be a bigger margin but you're also
taking on all the associated expenses of
having a company and so that like
finding the balance of of uh growing it
big enough to really cash in on that
when a lot of companies I care about a
lot of skaters running companies and
they're just shelling out their own
money just to keep the thing going
definitely so yeah I feel like that's
something a lot of people don't realize
and something that I've learned with
starting disorder is there is it's not
just about like selling a thousand
boards and then just like stacking up on
all this money like there's so there's
so much more than that so many expenses
and like yeah a lot of people just don't
see it that way it's no secret create
the Johnny Knoxville and I are a little
older too old to deliver the mail but we
can still lick the stamp
and I think we look pretty good right
here this Remains the only thing you've
ever signed for selling yeah this is the
only thing I've ever tried for selling
so much pressure when Steve owes filmed
everybody
grab these Johnny O skateboards while
you can I'd suggest you hurry